[Musik]
im tagesgespräch bei phoenix begrüße ich
ganz herzlich alexander gauland den
parteichef und fraktionsvorsitzenden der
afg im bundestag
hallo in berlin sie sind anscheinend
derjenige der es verursacht hat dass die
csu also die afg und sie dass die csu
und die spd abgestürzt in bayern was
sagen sie dazu
denn sie haben wir das thema flüchtlinge
und asylsuchende fahren dass die anderen
alle drauf gesprungen sind bis auf die
grünen oder die grünen hatten immer ein
anderes thema die grünen stehen uns
entferntesten dass es völlig klar
aber natürlich ist das thema flüchtlinge
das was die wähler die bürger im lande
nicht nur in bayern sondern auch in
hessen und anderswo interessiert und
dafür haben die beiden großen parteien
halt keine antwort was wir immer
behauptet es geht nicht so weiter aber
es geht natürlich doch immer so weiter
und das ist eine strafe die die csu
dafür bekommen hat und die spd gleich
mit die er nun fast in der
bedeutungslosigkeit verschwunden ist ja
das wird ja eigentlich im bund
bearbeitet die frage was hat das dann
eigentlich nur in der landtagswahl zu
suchen das ist immer so die die frage
die danach übrig bleibt hätte man nicht
vielleicht anders aber hätte hätte das
kennen wir schon
sie haben sie sind einer der gewinner
mit ihrer partei 10,2 in bayern geholt
haben sie ein bisschen sorge dass zum
beispiel sollte wie die freien wähler
ihnen demnächst noch ein bisschen mehr
stimmen abjagen weil es da eventuell
dann kräfte gibt in deutschland die
ihnen die stimmen in dem bereich
wegnehmen wo sie sie gerne haben
also bayern ist natürlich ein sonderfall
die freien wähler gab es immer und sie
sind tief verwurzelt in der bayerischen
politik geschichte
hubert aiwanger habe ich selber kennen
gelernt aus den anfangs gründen der kfd
gründung und ich weiß dass die freien
wähler natürlich menschen die sonst zu
uns gekommen wären von der csu weil sie
unzufrieden sind bei ihm und bei den
freien wählern gelandet sind das gibt es
aber in
keinem anderen bundesland die freien
wähler sind wie wir für gegen
massenimmigration sie sind gegen den
euro
sie haben aber bestimmte lokale
eigenheiten die sie weder in hessen noch
in niedersachsen noch sonst wo finden
insofern ist das ein sonderfall
aber ja ohne die freien wähler werden
wir noch stärker geworden da haben sie
völlig beide ein bisschen weniger platz
im konservativen lager dann für sie aber
was ist wenn das was sie fordern frau
merkel da irgendwie ja weggemobbt oder
wie auch immer weggenommen wird oder sie
irgendwann selber von sich aus sagt ich
gehe und dann in der cdu oder in der
union insgesamt
das besinnen in richtung ein bisschen
mehr konservativ zu werden dann platz
greift dann wäre er noch weniger platz
für sie also wissen sie das was wäre
wenn da bin ich noch sehr skeptisch ich
sehe im moment noch nicht dass die cdu
eingesehen hat dass das was frau merkel
ab 2015 gemacht hat durchgehend falsch
ist und da müsste man dann auch sehen
wenn sie wirklich weg wäre wer kommt
danach was wird dann für eine politik
umgesetzt
da sind mir alles zu viel könnte und
wäre
davor haben wir im moment nun gar keine
sorge wenn frau merkel weg wäre hätten
wir ein großes ziel erreicht und das ist
im interesse deutschlands auch völlig
richtig und deswegen bin ich immer sehr
dafür
und sie hätten ein feindbild weniger was
machen sie dann ach wissen sie es gibt
so viele vereint bilder in der cdu ich
sagte ja gerade ich sehe nicht dass
führende cdu leute in dem sie herrn
günther oder nehmen sie frau kramp
karrenbauer die laufen doch derselben
flüchtlingspolitik hinterher von herrn
günther kommt diese schnapsidee mit dem
spurwechsel
von da her da gibt es noch so viele
feindbilder wenn man mir gar keine
sorgen
was muss ich jetzt eigentlich davon
halten das habe ich nun gestern auch
mitgenommen bei den pressekonferenzen
auch bei der afg dass die jetzt nun auch
in die mitte wollen also nicht mehr
konservativ sondern in der mitte was
soll das bedeuten was wollen sie da
drängen sich doch eh schon
also ich hab gar nicht von der mitte
gesprochen sondern ich bin gefragt
worden ob wir langfristig mittel bis
langfristig auch verantwortung
übernehmen natürlich muss eine partei
mittel bis langfristig verantwortung
übernehmen aber dann muss sie sehr viel
stärker seien als wir bis jetzt sind
damit nicht mit ihr schlitten gefahren
werden kann so ähnlich wie herr aiwanger
das in ihrem beitrag gerade ausgedrückt
hat das würde auch für uns gelten
von mitte habe ich gar nicht gesprochen
aber natürlich rein ich muss mir die
parteien anschauen
die grünen sind sozusagen das klassische
gegenteil von uns mit spd und linken
verbindet uns nichts eine n geänderte
cdu eine gewandelte cdu die die fehler
von 2015 nicht nur auf arbeitet sondern
auch einsieht und abstellt die wäre
natürlich in ferner zukunft eine
möglichkeit für eine koalition
die fragen stellen sich jetzt überhaupt
nicht sie stellen sich möglicherweise in
den ostdeutschen bundesländern wo wir
2009 10 wahlen haben aber da mache ich
mir jetzt noch keine so das warten wir
mal noch ab aber wird ihnen nicht
manchmal ein bisschen schwindlig an hand
an angesichts dieser wahl ergebnisse
dieser vorlegen und zwar deswegen frage
ich das weil sie müssen ein interesse
daran haben dass sie eine gesund
gewachsene partei haben die so gesund
wächst dass sie beispielsweise
irgendwann regierungsfähig würde bei
diesem extrem wachstum und bei diesen
zahlen ja ist das dann gesund aus ihrer
sicht oder machen sie sich da auch
manchmal sorgen also wie viele kluge
leute aber natürlich ein schnelles
wachstum
bringt immer wieder probleme mit sich
für den die wir auch versuchen zu
meistern
ich kann mir abläufe und geschichte
nicht aussuchen das heißt wie hat
bismarck mal so schön gesagt wenn der
mantel der geschichte weht muss man ihn
ergreifen und die afg hat diesen mann zu
treffen und das ist auch gut so was gut
ist für deutschland ja dann macht ihnen
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen sorge dass
der verfassungsschutz eventuell bei
ihnen ein bisschen genauer hinschaut
oder also da muss man unterscheiden
das ist natürlich auch ein herrschafts
mittel und im moment habe ich überhaupt
keine sorge vor den verfassungsschutz
der hat auch nichts zu beobachten weil
es da nichts gibt manche haben wir
natürlich ja natürlich weiß ich auch
dass wenn der verfassungsschutz und
flächendeckend beobachten würde ist auf
die innere zusammensetzung der partei
sich negativer auswirken können das ist
schon klar
hochschullehrer beamte polizisten haben
dann gewisse schwierigkeiten insofern
wollen wir das in keiner weise und wir
werden das mit allen mitteln bekämpfen
das hat ja auch gestern mein co
vorsitzender jörg nolte deutlich gesagt
für die wähler ist das erst mal eher
etwas positives denn da sind wir wieder
opfer das ist typisch wie andere mit uns
umgehen von daher werden wir eher
gewinnen als verlieren
das was sie ansprechen ist eher eine
langfristige problematik die ich
überhaupt nicht bestreiten würden dass
das wäre schlimm wenn sie es bestreiten
würden es gibt ja doch diese schulter
schlüsse die dann doch auch manchmal im
bild erlebbar sind zwischen leuten von
ihnen und dann noch irgendwelchen rechts
oder rechten gruppen auch dieses thema
antisemitismus das versuchen sie jetzt
abzuräumen mit dem abgeordneten gedeon
in
stuttgart das ist ja an sich lobenswert
wenn sie daran gehen aber glauben sie
dass das in diesem in dieser partei so
inhomogen diese momentan ist möglich
sein wird ich weiß nicht warum das nicht
möglich sein sollte ja ich habe das
immer gesagt wir sind ein gieriger
haufen
da müssen sie sich mit vielen
auseinandersetzen und jahr in unserer
partei gibt es eine berechtigte sorge
vor einer wie wir das so schön nennen
distanzritt is das nich ununterbrochen
von irgendwas distanziert aber es ist
auch klar und das habe ich gerade in
anstand jetzt beim einem foul an huckle
wieder ganz deutlich gesagt sollten
einige leute bei uns sein
die glauben dass der nationalsozialismus
etwas gutes war dann gehören die nicht
in die partei und müssen mit aller kraft
bekämpft und ausgeschlossen werden also
keine distanziert es aber klare trennung
von dingen die nichts mit der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
zu tun haben ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für das gespräch und wir haben
es gar nicht geschafft über die hessen
wahl zu reden dass du nur vielleicht
beim nächsten mal ich herzlich
dankeschön alexander gauland st